how did it get to the point where you
are now a single father
because it's quite rare
yeah i mean
um
to be honest me and my daughter's mother
we were together for a long time um
but when it come to an end it just was
it was it was natural to me to kind of
assume the role of being a full-time
parent i mean
um my lifestyle suited it because i work
in music so most of my work comes on the
weekends so i have that freedom to be
around during the week when there's
responsibility involved
um
but what i would say though is that we
worked very hard to get to a point now
where we both have a big role in our
daughter's life so
there isn't any animosity now there
isn't any tension now there's no drama
now and i think that in the beginning
you have to really meander your way
through that to work out
are you doing what's best for the child
because listening to half of the
conversation
from the other side of the camera
in this debate tonight
there's lots of trivialization i find
with with the raising of children it's
like we've all been blessed well you and
i have been blessed so not all of us us
three have been blessed with children
and i find that some of the arguments
that parents can have
are are so minor in the grand context of
life of raising that child is so minor
no i i agree um
however
i think that um
like i said because the child is
normally with the mother
those
let's say petty arguments
normally come from that side
i had i had marsha at the beginning when
we first broke up we had a few
ding dongs i think that's expected when
you break up with um with anyone whether
you've got children or not you have a
few ding dongs at the end um
i mean i think that
you're right it is rare
but i don't think that makes me um
exceptional some people look at me like
i'm some sort of unicorn sometimes when
i tell my story but it's like it's not
it's not that deep like we had made we
made a decision to have a child
and we've tried our best to do the best
we can and you know i'm very proud of
the job we've done i think
i think a lot of the time um when it
comes to using a child as a pawn
[Music]
women know how to tell stories
right and a lot of the time women are
believed
especially when it comes to the family
court system um a woman can say
a man can um
he's quote-unquote abusive he's
quote-unquote narcissistic he's
quote-unquote whatever it is that she
makes up to i guess alienate the father
from that child she's more likely to be
believed than a father saying oh the
reason why i want to take the child like
in in a lot of cases a woman has to damn
near be caught strangling her child
for that child to be removed from
her you know it's a crazy story that i
heard in the u.s um
there was a mother that gave her kid up
for adoption even though the father
wanted it
and the father like had no rights in the
court system
because she chose to give it up for
adoption
yeah like father's rights in the court
system as i said yeah i've spoken to so
many different men um when it comes to
the court system and the family court
system specifically in the uk and the us
is so heavily skewed towards uh
women that you remember i don't know if
you remember in 2004 with fathers for
justice when they scold buckingham
palace right i don't know if you know
the story pearl so over here in 2004
there's a organization called fathers
for justice right and they are their
single fathers or their fathers
separated from their children and they
want justice to try and see their
children they went they got to the point
where they had to they went to
buckingham palace risked their lives
put on a batman suit a spider-man suit
and scaled buckingham palace and put a
banner up saying fathers for justice and
i'm just thinking if men have to get to
the point where they can actually lose
their lives because if you're going it's
like going on the white house lawn
trying to get on the white house you're
going to get shot do you know what i
mean but if men have to go to that
degree to try and tell the government
look something needs to change here i
have a stat so one study in 2004
confirmed that divorced people have a
higher suicide rates than their married
peers and that divorced men are eight
times more likely to kill themselves
than divorced women's overall correct i
think when fathers are removed from
their children um
people assume that a lot of fathers just
deadbeats they don't care about their
children but a lot of the time it
affects them mentally and they could be
in financial ruins over it too yes i
mean men men need purpose
right i think that when you have
children and you want to be a good man
children give you purpose
so if a woman is able to remove that
at will even sometimes on a whim
your life can become meaningless right
and
i'm fortunate to have never experienced
that and i hope i never do never have to
go for any legal troubles or anything
like that
but if i did
and i couldn't see my daughter
i wouldn't want to live
and that's the reality that i think
when women play games
um
they don't take that into account
because they're in that like you said
they're emotional creatures women are
emotional creatures more often than not
and they don't have the rationale to go
actually let's take a step back and look
at this that's not all women i'm i'm not
generalizing there's some great single
mothers that get on great with their
dads
but on the whole you hear more stories
about it
and i think that
people are just expected to just look at
men and go oh well he'll get on with it
yeah he's fine he'll get on with it like
he'll be stoic he'll he'll keep his
stiff upper lip and he'll crack on but
it's not really like that for men
because you know when we talk about our
emotions about kids you don't talk to
women about your emotions with your kids
you talk to other dads yes and you don't
have that conversation women don't know
how we really feel yeah they don't
it's it's it's kind of mad when you when
you talk about your experience with your
daughter and things because i think
being a dad can be i'm not a dad but
from what i've seen before i have um
conversations with other people being a
dad can be such a thankless job
because
when you're
doing things right when you're doing
everything perfect society tells you you
should be doing that right like you're
meant to be that's meant to be what
you're doing when you're not bare
minimum exactly exactly when you're not
perfect
that child is going to end up resenting
you at some point and so it's it's kind
of crazy um seeing you sit here and
saying these things because
you know obviously god forbid your child
ever goes up to despise you or anything
like that but it's such a hard job being
a dad
and you know you seem to be taking on
and you love it so i do love it that's
great
i have a question um do you guys think
that women are entitled to child support
yes or no
entitled in what context um so
like do you think that the child child
support should exist basically
um
that's so nuanced the question i mean
should it exist
i i think i think it is there to kind of
give people that sense of you have a
responsibility when things fall apart
but
i i don't know i don't i don't know if
it should exist or not because
you know you didn't get paid to have the
kid in the first place
i mean i think if you're if
it's a tricky one i think if you if
you're good and you're a good person and
you want to look after your child you
will look after your child i don't think
for me i think state involvement is with
children is a bit of a no-no yeah it's
not what the guys should do it's like
should the government force men to pay
i don't like the word force i mean i
mean because if you don't if you don't
pay child support you go to jail yeah so
you are forced it's like you don't in
the uk you don't go to jail child
support in uk but in america um
i think i think it depends doesn't does
the opposite work in reverse in the
united states that's what you're
referencing so if you have a man who's
got custody of his child is the woman
obligated to pay child support in
america
um is she up it's not as common um it
does happen but they're usually
headlines because it's the exception
rather than the rule i don't i don't
believe in child support at all i think